Taylor Swift has been named The Time
Magazine person of the year some
Liberals are upset by this because a
basically normal white lady won the
award some conservatives are upset by
this because a vaguely liberal lady won
the award and to all of them I quote
Chris Christie this is a smart
accomplished woman you should stop
insulting listen here I have a decent
amount of credibility on this issue
because I was the 2006 Time person of
the year myself and I say she totally
deserves it or she almost totally
deserves it really if we're talking
about influence and dominating the
global conversation it should have been
Elon but Elon already gave it or Elon
rather already won the the time award
two years ago and Taylor Swift is
genuinely a phenomenon she is not a scop
people actually really like her I don't
really get it because I'm neither a
millennial woman nor a homosexual but I
am convinced that her popularity is not
contrived I have seen too many
intelligent put together accomplished
women lose their minds for Taylor
Swift's tour shell out thousands of
dollars refresh Ticket Master for hours
it's very weird I don't get it but I am
not the target audience and I'm not
thrilled that she's vaguely liberal but
of all the people that time could have
picked Taylor Swift is easily one of the
best she's clean cut she's pretty and
best and most shocking of all she's
normal as far as the liberal press is
concerned that is about as big a win as
any conservative could possibly hope for
this is a smart accomplished woman and
people should stop insulting her I'm
Michael NS this the Michael NS
[Music]
show
speaking of smart accomplished women for
all of you loyal listeners and viewers
out there no I did not get new intro
music that is new music from the
soundtrack of the number one movie in
America lady Ballers listen to it now on
Spotify Apple music Pandora or wherever
you enjoy your music and of course watch
lady Ballers exclusively on daily wi
plus also this episode's brought to you
by good ranchers head on to
goodranchers.com subscribe today with
Cod nolles kwes to claim your free
Limited stock holiday ham before it
sells out a school board president in
Pennsylvania just swore the oath of
office on a stack of banned books which
was mostly deviant pornography I guess
all pornography is deviant but some of
it is especially deviant that's what she
did so we'll get to that in one second
first though speaking of
achievements moving from Taylor to the
political field
I'm really proud of v ramaswami v has
just unlocked a new political
specifically Republican achievement he
has been compared to a Nazi on CNN that
guy is dangerous that's dangerous um
when those people are saying Jews will
not replace us Jews will not replace us
that slogan sits on top of a very sick
and twisted view that if you bring
enough people of color here we are so
deficient we are so stupid we are so
unwanted that we will be zombies to fill
out the the ranks for some democratic
party agenda that Jewish people are
manipulating and driving forward that
leads to violence uh that puts at risk
Jewish people that puts at risk people
of color it is wrong and the smug
condescending way that he just spewed
this poison out is very very dangerous
because he won't stop Trump but he's
going to outlive Trump by about 50 years
and you're watching the rise of an
American demagogue that is a very very
despicable person and I I'm I literally
I I was I was shaking listening to him
talk because a lot of people don't know
that is one step away from Nazi
propaganda coming out of his mouth
that's what that's it that's what he was
doing if you listened really carefully
not if you listen to the words that V
said which were totally unobjectionable
but if you listen really carefully to
like the dog whistle pitches in between
all the notes and the words then what he
actually said sounded a lot
like no I don't think so I don't did you
hear any Nazi propaganda from V
ramaswami what V said
was there's a program of mass migration
coming into this country that the libs
want because it displaces Americans and
it gives them an advantage he says they
call it a conspiracy theory they call it
a a great replacement but it's it's the
explicit totally open program of the
Democrat Party to get take take away the
borders and flood the country with
foreigners because it gives them an
electoral advantage that's what he
said and then van Jones hears that
here's that completely unobjectionable
obviously true statement he says and you
know what he's implying here what he's
implying is that the Jews are the most
rotten evil people on Earth and ought to
be rounded up and sent to get camps wait
what when did VI mention the Jews
huh well secretly that's what he was
implying and he's a demagogue and he
good grief man good on him good on him I
if I were vake I wouldn't be offended by
that at all you are not you are not a
serious mainstream conservative until
CNN calls you a Nazi you're not if if
CNN is not calling you a Nazi then you
might as well sign up with the Democrat
Party to to to be called a Nazi by the
mainstream left is is the barrier to
entry for a conservative po they start
to call you a Nazi if you if you gently
Advocate that we just cut taxes a little
bit okay the barrier to entry is not
that high and V has passed it so another
the guy's got a lot of achievements in
his life
okay he he's a self-made man he's a
graduate of Yale law school he started a
very successful company he sold it for
something like a billion dollars he is a
best-selling author he is a presidential
candidate who went from no name
recognition to being one of the top guys
in the race and now the top achievement
is the Liars at CNN call him a Nazi good
job
meanwhile the rest of the establishment
not just on the Democrat side but even
on the Republican side of the
establishment they
are upset about a problem that V does
not
have part of the knock on V is he's this
young precocious guy but the rest of the
the political establishment is upset at
the old people who are still in politics
Jeb Bush Jeb Jeb uh just criticized the
disproportionate influence of old people
in politics he said as a 70-year-old
person I am part of the problem it is
time for my generation to get off the
stage politically I hear this a lot
probably a lot of rock ribbed
conservatives even are going to agree
with what Jeb says here I do not I do
not suffer from
agism it's very fashionable to say all
these old people they don't know what
they're doing we need to make way for
the youths hey man I'm a conservative I
don't put that much stock in the youths
okay I actually think that with age
comes wisdom and sometimes with age
wisdom does not come like in the case of
Joe Biden but sometimes it does and I
don't want to discriminate against old
people in fact the word Senate like the
US Senate comes from the Latin word senx
which means old guy so I I think it's
perfect find have old guys in politics
the problem with our political order
right now is not old people it's a
certain strain of old thinking that's
the problem does anyone believe that Jeb
Bush wants more V ramaswami in politics
V is like 12 years old he he is not an
old man by any means do you think Jeb
wants more VES no way I'm sure I'm sure
Jeb hates what V is bringing into the
Republican Party because what V is
bringing to the Republican party is
largely a repudiation of the Bush
family's contribution to the Republican
Party does does Jeb really hate I don't
know Joe Biden did Jeb really hate that
the Old Guard of does Jeb hate Mitch
McConnell no I don't think
so it's an it's an old line of thinking
that is the problem the proof of this
here is Donald Trump because even if you
hate Donald Trump you probably don't
hate Donald Trump because of his
age Donald Trump has much more in common
politically with the youngest prominent
figures in the Republican party right
now than he does with the old guys
Donald Trump has much more in common
with
vake JD Vance Josh Holly Blake Masters
the the group that is currently called
the new right Trump has much more in
common with them than he does with Mitch
McConnell Joe Biden Nancy Pelosi John
McCain Mitt Romney he's got way more in
common with the young guys that's not
that the big divide is not age the big
divide is ideas there are some
Republicans who want to
maintain the feckless consensus that
predominated on the right after the Cold
War and throughout the Bush
Administration and even even into the
early Obama administration and that
feckless consensus was ignore social
issues just focus on projecting American
might abroad and cutting taxes that was
the consensus I mean it was articulated
in fact by George HW Bush just after the
Cold War there was a big debate in the
Republican party it was George HW Bush
versus P Buchanan George HW Bush said we
won the Cold War now we have to win the
peace and we've only got to focus on
expanding our economic might to the
exclusion basically of every other
question and Pap Buchanan said uh-uh
we're fighting a culture War he gave a
very famous speech called the culture
War speech at the 1992 Republican
National Convention and Bush won and
Buchanan lost and the bush view
predominated for 26 years and you saw it
throughout the Clinton Administration
and the Bush
Administration it was it was the two
were not all that different you saw it
into the early tea party even just focus
on cutting taxes shrinking government
forget the cultural issues the leaders
of the Tea Party espe especially the the
political leaders of the Tea Party I'm
thinking of Paul Ryan I'm thinking of
the Young Guns so-called in Congress the
the Grassroots of the tea party was was
much more cultural but the the political
leadership at the top focused almost
exclusively on economic issues and it
didn't work okay and then Trump comes
around and he brings back the Buchanan
view is is Jeb Bush really concerned
about age or is he concerned about
something a little bit deeper now when
you want to learn about these deep
questions you got to check out Hillsdale
College right now head on to
hillsdale.edu are you a few years or
decades out of school and wondering what
the heck did I even learn and what was
the point you might even be thinking I
don't have time to learn something new
well if that's you you're not alone and
it's not too late Hillsdale College is
offering more than 40 free online
courses learn about the works of CS
Lewis the rise and fall of the Roman
Republic or the history of the ancient
Christian church with Hillsdale
College's online courses if you're not
sure where to start check out CS Lewis
on Christianity in this seven lecture
course you will examine some of Lewis's
classic Works including Mere
Christianity the screw tape letters and
the abolition of man you will also see
what lwis had to say about scripture
prayer suffering Joy Heaven and Hell the
course is self-paced so that you can
start whenever and wherever enroll now
in CS Lewis on Christianity to discover
Lewis's core lessons on Christianity and
how to apply Faith to your life go to
hillsdale.edu to enroll there's no cost
it's easy to get started hillsdale.edu
enroll hillsdale.edu
NOS now speaking of new problems and not
dealing with them we did a segment a
couple days ago on this porn
investigation from sound investigations
we had ardan young come on the show this
was an exclusive uh that we broke and
the the clip now has been seen well over
five million times on Twitter alone I I
don't even know how many on YouTube and
elsewhere it went totally completely
viral and the reason it went viral
was uh
two two shocking revelations from the
undercover footage with the senior
PornHub writers one was that and I
didn't find this all that shocking they
knew that kids were looking at their
stuff they they're admitting that they
they at least know that on the camera
and we know that whenever there are age
verification laws passed in States
PornHub pulls their business out of the
states because they don't want to comply
with that so I didn't find that all that
shocking I think that's something we all
knew the thing that was really shocking
was you had two senior writers for
PornHub first of all PornHub has writers
apparently it does or porn whatever the
PornHub they keep changing their name so
it was PornHub then that was owned by
mindgeek then that was owned by now Alo
they keep changing it because it's a
disgusting company so they they don't
want to have to uh maintain any kind of
reputation they just have to keep
changing the names this is this is how
the left used uses words and euphemisms
they have to keep changing them because
the underlying reality of what they're
saying is so bad so they've got these
senior writers and the senior writers
said on camera they
said one strategy that we use to expand
the market is we slip gay and themes
into the straight
porn and the reason that we do that is
that we seek to convert their words not
mine the straight guys to look at all
this even weirder por so I thought that
was pretty shocking because I was raised
to be told that sexual orientation is
innate it's immutable nothing can
possibly change you can't convert
anybody right that's what we've been
told our whole lives and yet senior
staff at the most powerful most
knowledgeable porn company in the world
they've got more data than anybody on
this subject they're saying no yes you
can not only can you convert people from
One sexual preference or desire to
another but that's our business model
that's our strategy so anyway I was
pretty shocked at this clip goes out
there goes viral and then this is a
really weird headline The Advocate which
is some LGBT element magazine runs a
headline the headline says PornHub makes
you gay or conservative daily wire
pundit Michael nolles
claims did did I claim that
subheadline the
anti-lgbtq plus right-wing pundit
claimed that companies like bornhub are
secretly conspiring to make
cisgender a stupid word to make
cisgender straight men change their
sexual orientation and gender
identity now the problem with this
headline and subheader
is I I never claimed
that PornHub admitted that on
video so I don't know where they get
secretly for they're not secretly
conspiring it's on video I played the
video I don't I didn't do the
investigation I'm not making any
original claims at
all I just I just played a clip of the
actual porn company here so the actual
headline should read PornHub makes you
gay or PornHub
claims the big porn company is openly
conspiring to make or semi-open like
inspiring they're at least talking about
it over dinner dates where they don't
know they're being
recorded to make cisgender straight men
change their sexual orientation and
gender identity don't shoot the
messenger man I'm not even the messenger
I didn't even do the investigation I
just listened to a reporter discuss it
and then watched her footage where you
hear it straight from the horse's
mouth what is this
about I think probably my critics are
going to be surprised to hear my basic
conclusion from this whole thing which
is uh sure there's all sorts of debates
over sex and desire and porn and
morality
and the key to this story the key to the
PornHub is trying to The Straits story
again their video not my original
claims the key to it is
actually
capitalism or more precisely capitalism
unconstrained by morality
I this this was a key topic of my speech
a couple nights ago at Clemson which I
encourage all of you to watch it's
called kids are not Commodities
surrogacy and
IVF what we call capitalism what a lot
of people mistakenly defend as
capitalism today is not conservative
it's not right-wing it's it's not
something that Adam Smith would have
defended it's certainly not something
the found fathers would have defended
because what people are referring to as
capitalism today is totally
unconstrained by
morality and therefore
it puts the cart before the horse free
markets are good they're the most
efficient way to utilize resources in an
economy
but the purpose of that is to serve
human flourishing it's to serve the
political
order we do not exist as a political
Community to serve the market that's
called Mammon worship the market exists
to serve us and so capitalism which is a
word let's not forget popularized by
Carl marks okay capitalism which in its
current form is something that that much
more neatly uh would be revered by the
left than by the right because the left
turns everything into just a question of
money even people it commoditized even
people the right doesn't do that we
recognize that there's a lot more than
money in the world we realize that human
motivations go a lot deeper than just
material gain what what is called
capitalism today is absolutely
ghastly because it it has to grow it has
to expand it get it has to get you to
consume more and more if it's not
growing it's dying and so in the case of
porn which should be illegal anyway and
was illegal for most of American history
and most of the history of our
civilization they when when it comes to
porn you've already thrown morality out
the window by even permitting this stuff
to exist and to flourish but a lot of
people say well it's the free market
it's free speech in the middle of the
20th
century leftists decided that for the
first time ever porn was going to be
considered free speech that was never
the case in our country but at after
that point we we then said well in the
name of all holy free market we we've
got to allow this smut and degeneracy to
to thrive and to expand and then what
happens you got a porn company porn
companies got to expand if they get all
of the straight guys and the straight
guys are looking at all of the straight
porn well we got to get new products for
them you know they've they've seen all
of that we need to well how about if we
have a dude or how about we have like a
dude who looks like like a chick or vice
versa or like three guys in a billy goat
or whatever we it needs to get weirder
and weirder and weirder and more
varied not my
claim that is what the senior PornHub
staff is saying on air you got a problem
with that don't take it up with me take
it up with the corporation don't for
it's a pornhub's a corporation so if you
got a problem with that don't even just
take it up with the ideological left
take it up with the ways in which our
political economy has been so
extraordinarily perverted Ironically in
the name of capitalism which
conservatives supposedly like now when
we're talking about morality and the
basis for Morality you got to check out
the St Paul center right now go to
stpaul center.com I recently had my
friend Dr Scott Han on the show he's the
founder of the St Paul Center which is
one of the fastest growing Catholic
organizations in the world the St Paul
Center's mission is to give you the
tools you need to know to love scripture
better to become more confident in your
faith and most importantly to grow
closer to Christ himself in order to
achieve this the St Paul Center founded
a new digital learning platform called
EMAs Academy EMAs Academy features over
20 video courses book studies and
original series giving you the ability
to learn from world-class theologians
such as Dr Scott hun and Dr John bergsma
as if you were right there with them in
the classroom I absolutely love
everything they put out they're a great
place to start your exploration of your
faith their 12 session study by Dr Scott
hon is incredible he traces the meaning
of Holiness from its origins in
scripture to its appearance in our own
lives today this study will help you
experience the transformative power of
God's holiness start learning more about
church history how to interpret the
Bible the basics of Christian prayer and
more stpaul
center.com head on over there you can
begin exploring Emmas Academy
memberships are only 25 bucks per month
but you can sign up today for a two-e
free trial right now imagine what could
be possible if we were all to fortify
ourselves with a deeper understanding of
scripture and our faith do not miss this
opportunity to sign up today to begin
your journey with EMAs Academy lady
Ballers is the number one streaming
movie in the country it's not only on
dailywire Plus or I'm sorry it is only
on dailywire plus it's the number one
streaming movie on all of the all of the
uh big rankings but you can only watch
it on daily wi plus if you don't have a
dailywire Plus members let's take care
of that right now get 30% off new
dailywire plus annual memberships this
weekend only are you already a daily
wire plus member fantastic you can gift
a 30% off daily wire plus annual
membership to friends family members
co-workers even strangers give the gift
of the top movie in America and
unlimited access to all the incredible
content that the daily wire offers last
weekend lady balers broke our previous
record for a new release this weekend we
are set to shatter that record again
take a look at lady
balers the people have spoken lady
Ballers is the number one streaming
movie in America we're heroes it's a
drain up Festival bring the kids we
could dominate every woman's sport my
pronouns are I'm
strong watch the most triggering comedy
of the decade I was just invited to the
White House to give a talk on women's
rights you earn that you own it lady
Ballers exclusively on Deli wire Plus
number one baby not a bad start for our
first ever fulllength feature comedy
lady Ballers has a 92% audience score
with thousands of reviews it's time to
spread the word and watch the biggest
movie in America lady Ballers streaming
exclusively on dailywire plus get 30%
off dailywire plus annual memberships
this weekend only the perfect gift for
yourself or anyone on your Christmas
list go to dailywire.com subscribe to
get your 30% off dailywire plus
membership
now speaking of creepy content being
accessed by
kids new report out schools Across
America are encouraging minors
children to go onto Secret online LGBT
chat
rooms to discuss quote gender affirming
surgeries occult practices believe it or
not and other things with adults who
identify as
LGBT
seems to me if any
adults access these platforms they
should get a knock on the door from
Chris Hansen followed by the police but
it's not just that it's not just that
creepy adults are talking about these
things with
kids unsupervised by the kids parents to
without the knowledge of the kids
parents at
all it's that the schools are
encouraging it
Massachusetts has administrators who are
pushing youth to identify as l gbt qia a
plus I guess that's the new one that's
the one they're sticking with to qchat
which is a secret platform that connects
uh chat-based discussion groups for
lgbtq plus they forgot the IIA in that
one but it's got it it they got to add
the IIA I guess the platform is outdated
uh and questioning teens ages 13 to 19
can you
imagine can you imagine you you're a
parent and you find out that some
pervert School administrator told your
13-year-old kid to go onto a secret chat
room to talk with adults about weird sex
stuff can you imagine how difficult it
would be to restrain your worst impulses
and to remember that Vengeance Belongs
to the Lord and to allow the Civil
authority to take its course which it
won't do because the Civil Authority
promotes this can you fathom
that
reaction very difficult very difficult
to imagine restraint in that situation
the these chat rooms invite participants
to join conversations on everything from
queer youth activism to sex and
relationships to tarot cards isn't it
kind of weird isn't it kind of weird how
all this stuff just always seems to come
back to weird satanic imagery isn't that
and like occult practices and Demon
stuff it it's just funny huh funny how
that works all of this of course without
parental permission this website which
is a project of a bunch of LGBT Elemento
groups and pl Parenthood so you you have
the child sacrifice people in there too
they they have even equipped the website
with a Quick Escape so if your parents
walk by and see that your pervert School
administrators have encouraged you to go
talk about sex and Tarot cards with
weird adults whose identity you don't
know you can just very quickly X out of
it it and you just quick escape button
you're out so the parents won't find out
you don't want them to find out because
then they might tell you not to do that
and the school really really the school
wants to do the same thing the pornhub's
trying to do to you okay
Wisconsin it's not just Massachusetts
Wisconsin uh had students guided to
Trevor space which is a similar kind of
thing allows minors who identify as LGBT
they lost the Q and the IIA and the plus
to anonymously chat with adults on the
platform form this is a project of the
Trevor Project which is a radical
LGBT uh
organization uh this has been exposed
for a as a hotspot for graphic
conversations about sexual fetishes
adults giving minors advice on how to
discreetly obtain various uh sexual
paraphernalia and hide it from their
parents very very disturbing adults
detailing I'm not I'm not even going to
get into it adults detailing very very
disgusting depraved things for the
minors on the chat form on the platform
this is viar Germany kind of stuff this
is late Rome kind of stuff the worst
kind of
depravity you've ever read about in a
history book right
now at perhaps a a a much higher level
going
on obviously I agree with that you very
likely agree with that you you normal
people listening to the show now I know
look I know that there are some left
Wingers and even some radical left wiers
who listen to the show so maybe there
are a small number of you out there
who disagree with me and you say no no
Michael you don't you're totally
misrepresenting this and I'll tell you
from their perspective this is what
they're saying from their perspective
they're saying there are these kids who
are whatever are gay are they have these
uh sexual desires that are unusual and
they feel alone and they feel isolated
and an oppressive Society with a with a
false and cruel
morality uh forces them to stay in the
closet and deny their true selves and
these heroic adults are out there giving
their time giving their money in many
cases trying to save these poor
oppressed LGBT element ofp children from
their cruel evil parents and this evil
country founded on evil Christian
morality and they're they're going to
liberate them and bring them into the
truth and fullness of their identity
that's what they say that's what they
believe that's the justification for
this and so from their perspective I
think many of them have good
intentions which by the way pave the
road to hell those good intentions but I
bet they have good intentions some of
them some of them are perverts but some
of
them are are unknowingly perverts and
they they and they probably do have good
intentions they really really believe
all of this so who's right what is it is
this a bunch of weirdos grooming kids
into something that will harm them or is
this a bunch of wonderful helpful people
enlightened Brilliant Minds who are
saving children from oppression and
liberating
them you know my view and I think I know
your view but it's an open question and
and it's a question that the state will
weigh in on that the state must weigh in
on cuz the school is going to do one
thing or the other the school is either
going to encourage these chat sites or
the school is not going to encourage
these chat sites the school is going to
teach something it's either going to
teach that a boy can be a girl and
therefore if you're a boy but you think
you're a girl then you need to be
liberated and go on hormones and chop
yourself up and and be called by the
opposite pronouns or it's not going to
teach that the school's going to say no
actually boys can't be girls so you're
just confused and we're we're going to
try to give you a more correct
understanding of things but it's going
to teach something this the the state
has to weigh in which means that the
state has to have some kind of religious
View and even if you don't like the word
religion you're allergic to it the state
has to take some kind of view of human
nature and who we are how we know who we
are what we're here for those are all
religious questions we can pretend that
they're not if that if you'd prefer that
but either way the state has to have an
answer to it and has to enforce those
standards who's going to do that
traditionally that would be us we the
people that's that's the that's the true
American tradition you will hear the
radical squishes and the radical
individualists and the even the radical
Libertarians in some cases
saying that we have no right to impose
our views on others that's unamerican
now it man this is unamerican you
seriously think Thomas Jefferson would
have supported this this no you really
think George Washington would have
supported this kind of Filth and
degeneracy of course not so that means
that the view that you are claiming is
the Deep American true sense of freedom
is just wrong it's just ahistorical
you've been fed a lie you've been you've
bought a bill of goods okay
and that means we need to correct our
perception first before we can then have
the brains and the spine and maybe some
other body parts to correct that
perception for the country and return to
something resembling a reasonable
American tradition now speaking of the
schools there's a lady she's just sworn
in as Schoolboard president in
Pennsylvania and she wanted to take the
oath of office usually you swear the
oath of office on a Bible if you're not
Christian and you're a public office
holder say you're Muslim I guess you
could swear it on the
Quran I if let's say you're Jewish I
guess you could swear it on the Torah
said but you swear it on on a book
traditionally that that means a lot to
you that you that and that speaks to
obligations that you have beyond the
material world that you because what
you're vowing is I will uphold my office
with Integrity I will not deceive I will
not cheat I will not lie so help me God
because even even if I won't be held to
account in this life I will be held to
account in the life to come that's why
you do it it's it's a book that you hold
sacred and the books that this lady
holds sacred are
pornography this woman Karen
Smith decided to swear the oath of
office on a stack of baned books this of
course thanks to our friends at Libs of
Tik Tock who that you know she just digs
up all the greatest stuff the books are
not even the usual band books that that
people site you know uh I don't know the
Harper Lee novel what's that called you
know I can't believe I for it's one of
the most famous novels ever written they
sometimes say that that that's a ban
book or I don't know catcher in the Ry
or something no it's not but those aren
the books that are really banned the
books that are banned are usually weirdo
porn that they're putting into
elementary
schools well what are these books
flamer by Henry Holt all boys aren't
Blue by something
Johnson there's a Tony Morrison novel in
there which the reason people shouldn't
read Tony Morrison she's not a very good
writer but not because it's pornographic
exactly lilan Duncan Donna Gart so even
here flamer what we're talking about is
porn like in this case like weird gay
porn I'm glad to see gender queer wasn't
in there I'm sure that someone's going
to include that too look this makes
sense to me it makes sense that the the
libs would consider the most sacred
books in the world to be books that are
poorly written and porn pornographic in
some
cases that's what they hold
sacred bad writing weak art and
obscenity that's what they hold sacred
they don't see it like that what they
see it like is that they are swearing
the oath on freedom and openness they
have a mistaken conception of freedom
and un openness we want to read every
there should be no baned books and the
irony here of course is the the book
that one would traditionally swear the
oath of office on is the one book that
is actually banned in schools and that's
the Bible and and this Schoolboard lady
seems fine with that because she she
kicked the Bible out of her oath of
office that's the iron there's only one
book that is actually banned in schools
throughout the country and that book is
the Bible the rest of the stuff your
mileage may vary by municipality but
largely the weirdo porn stuff and the
bad writing and the nonsense is
permitted they want Total
openness now this is attractive even to
a lot of right-wingers they say that's
right we want freedom and they view
Freedom as being just total openness to
everything which as we've said many
times on this show that's not what
Freedom actually is that's not what our
Founders thought freedom was that's not
what the great Statesman of our
civilization of thought that freedom
is but I guess my question to them is
you want Total openness you hold as most
sacred just the the total openness to
anything and everything without coming
to any conclusions
whatsoever
why why why is that
good what's so good about presenting a
10-year-old with porn in the classroom
well what do you what do you want to do
ban
books in some cases yes but at least for
certain people and you know certain ages
but put that aside for a
second why is it good you sound like a
book burner hold on quit it with the
invective quit it with the insults just
can you give me an explanation of why it
is what good is achieved by giving
pornography to a
10-year-old
well then they're really they're really
open right to what end for what our
founding fathers talked about the
blessings of liberty and they had a way
better conception of Liberty than we do
today but when you talk about the
blessings of liberty you recognize that
Liberty is an instrument to an end to a
good it's not a good in and of itself
it's it's a it's a it's a means to an
end so what is the good to be achieved
there they fall silent they would look
at you like you have three heads we got
to talk about these things though and
when you want to talk you got to check
out pure talk right now go to Pur
talk.com NES kwes P talk has you covered
for the holidays with a free Moto G 5G
phone no gimmicks no tradeing necessary
just sign up for p talks unlimited talk
unlimited text and 15 gigs of data you
can get all of this for just 35 bucks
and you will get the Moto g5g phone for
free but here's the deal you need to
move fast because these phones are
almost gone so if your current phone is
on life support upgrade for free with
pure talk the new Moto g5g boasts a
two-day battery life an exceptional quad
pixel camera and a whole lot more Pure
Talk gives you America's most Dependable
5G Network at half the price so make the
switch today go to Pur talk.com kwes get
this exclusive offer and select the plan
that's right for your family Pure Talk
gives you American because most
Dependable 5G Network at half the price
make the switch today P talk.com to
claim your free moto 5G phone with a
qualifying plan head on over there right
now get pure talk simply smarter
Wireless my favorite comment yesterday
is from the drummers workshop at norms
music who says what a gentleman chrris
Christie he was so nice at that last
debate being Nikki Haley's White Castle
I mean White Knight that's not nice
that's not I would not make a joke like
that so that's kind of funny but that's
not he is a smart intelligent woman and
you should stop insulting him this
mailbag is sponsored by P talk go to PE
talk.com kwes to claim your free Moto
g5g phone with a qualifying plan take it
away hi Michael guess who it is no not
your uncle who smokes too much it's Dr
fouchy I was uh wondering just one
question why are you not wearing your
mask just because I'm am not in the
public eye anymore does not mean you do
not have to answer to my unipotent power
you must wear your mask you are exposing
you and everyone you know to the new
Corona virus Death Star variant that's
very dangerous and very deadly please
wear a
mask you're right you're you're right Dr
faty that I don't know what I was
thinking especially you hear I'm just a
little tiny bit stuffy right now so who
know I might have
covid-19 covid
23 covid 27 there's going to be a new
covid just before every presidential
election cycle so you're right I'm sorry
doctor you got me next
one hi Michael my brother-in-law thinks
it would be morally okay to donate sperm
for money I on the other hand do not he
would argue that it's a simple exchange
and that he would have no obligation to
the life created since it's done
professionally and
anonymously I think it's equivalent to
prostitution for men because you're
essentially selling your body for money
and you're working in the sex industry
he disagrees that it's like prostitution
but has no argument against why we're
both Christians and so it got me curious
and I've asked around to other believers
and they would seem to side with my
brother-in-law I'm shocked by this help
me win this debate how can I convince my
brother-in-law and my friends um to see
the moral issues with donating sperm and
how irresponsible it really is love the
show and love the work you do
thanks here's the first thing you ask
him if you want to show the intrinsic
immorality of donating sperm I mean
there's so many many more serious issues
here but here's the first
one how you going to donate the
sperm what you don't want to get too
graphic especially you're talking to
your family member or something
but what is the method by which one
donates
sperm is that action virtuous and holy
or is that action intrinsically evil and
Gravely wrong and obviously immoral and
shameful is
it and even if people are confused about
this today because there's a lot of
religious
confusion is that
action something that Christians since
the Advent of our civilization and in
fact long even before the Advent of our
Lord and the Nativity and the
crucifixion and the resurrection is that
something that the line of our faith has
held to be good or obviously immoral and
the sin of Onin for all of history what
do you think it is what do you it's
obviously the latter guys so uh just
there that's the very first thing the
the action of donating sperm would
involve an immoral act uh after that
because some people try to whitewash
that they try to say no no that you know
that's that's okay actually now
everything changed now and that
obviously shameful action is really good
and it's totally fine it's just a health
matter he says oh it's it's a it's a
health facility it's administered by
professionals yeah so are abortion
clinics man it doesn't make them good
they're they're very bad but but then in
this case what he would be doing is
fathering a child and then abandoning
that child which is a a grave evil that
you know when it comes to procreation
the only the only party that can be said
to have any rights is the child the
child has a right to his natural mother
and father and to be conceived in the
conjugal
act and I went into some detail as to
why this is the case in my speech that I
gave a couple of nights ago at Clemson
on kids are not Commodities surrogacy
and
IVF I guess that's another part here
this commoditized sex and human life
people are not
property people are not property to be
bought and sold the way we know people
are not property is that people have
rights and so if people have any rights
at all that means that people cannot
have a right to other
people you have a right to property you
don't have a right to other people
because those other people also have
rights so in this case because of
capitalism unored from moral ity we're
commoditizing everything and the analogy
you make with prostitution is apt
because in prostitution we commoditize
human beings and we treat human beings
like nothing more than instruments and
flesh and property to be used for the
gratification of another's low lowest uh
appetites and here it's even Graver
because we're treating people and we're
treating sex as property to conceive
another person and then to sell that
person so deep deeply evil uh not worth
it at all and gross so tell your brother
to just give your brother maybe a little
corrective smack and say come to your
senses not I'm not saying assault him
I'm not saying punch him you know it's
like like the The Legend of St Nicholas
uh at the Council of NAA talking to the
herzi arch Aras it's not that he punched
him in the face he gave him a corrective
slap you know get a hold of yourself man
what's the matter with you like Don
Corone talking to Johnny Fontaine next
one hey Michael love the show my
question for you you is about how to
successfully and gracefully navigate
arguments within your marriage so many
couples struggle with this I think and
they struggle with how to have a
disagreement without yelling or getting
mean at each other and you have said
before that no husband or wife should be
raising their voice or yelling at each
other in an argument so I wanted to get
your suggestions on how couples should
uh gracefully navigate disagreements
within their marriage thank you so much
for the
advice uh wives should submit to their
husbands and husbands should love their
wives I'm not the first to say
but that will that will help a
lot and probably that's a controversial
piece of advice in our decadent age but
the reason for this
is there will be a head of household
there there has to
be two people don't make a very good
democracy so someone's going to have the
final say and the question is how are
you going to have the final say is it
going to be the
husband I guess that's patriarchy is it
going to be the wife I guess that's
matriarchy or is that going to be a
constant negotiation where one person
wins and has the final say this time and
another person has the final say this
time where you just don't ever come to
an agreement and then you have even more
division in your marriage and
for all of history at least in our
civilization and really everywhere else
uh the husband has been the head of the
household and has the final say so that
that has seemed to work out pretty well
for civilization so far in recent years
we have this feminist idea where either
the woman has the final say or you just
never come to an agreement and it's but
then then you're then your marriage
becomes like a business
negotiation everything becomes
commoditized this is a theme we're
seeing throughout our culture and you
don't want your marriage to be a
business negotiation you know you want
you want your marriage to be two people
coming together and and becoming one
flesh and having their love be so real
that it actually creates new people so I
would I would encourage strong feminism
out the window and then my my biggest
advice is for the men which is you don't
you don't want to Lord power over your
wife you want to hear your wife's
opinion if you feel that you can
reasonably accommodate that even even if
it will inconvenience you then if your
if your reason leads you to the place
where you think okay uh this it would be
good for us to do this even though I
don't particularly want to then do that
but if your reason leads you to a place
where you say no it is objectively good
that I or you or we do such and such and
the good of that outweighs the bad of
that and there's nothing evil in that
and here's my argument for it
and and you're still at a disagreement
then you've you've got to make a final
say and and maybe in charity and love
for your wife you try to do some nice
things for her around that uh but but
you're you're not going to do it with
feminism or a democracy it's not not
good for families look at what it's done
to families over the last 50 70 years
next
question hi Michael I love your show and
I was wondering if you could rate your
producers from best to worst producer
Davies producer Danny Professor Jacob
and young
marel thanks love
you davies's obviously last no question
it's goes without saying
um
ordinarily I would I would say ladies
first you know but I actually I think I
have to give it to producer Dany here
because producer
Dany has the most difficult job of
anyone because producer Dany I send in
my script you know and I say okay hey I
need a clip of Ross perau using the word
anti- disestablishmentarianism sometime
in 1972 can you find that for me Danny
and then Danny at 4 in in the morning
has to go scouring the internet you know
has to go to libraries in The Dewy
Decimal System to find whatever clip I
want so that's absolutely brutal
sometimes we do that on the
Fly I would say Danny is at the top
followed by we've already established Mr
Davies obviously way down at the bottom
followed by the young marel of course
because she's the only one of of them
who is delightful you know and not just
a just a you know sort of broken husk of
a man and then and then I guess that
would leave uh Professor Jacob in the
penultimate spot but not the last place
because I don't want to be called
anti-semitic all right let's get to some
written
mailbag plus you know some people have
suggested that Professor Jacob should be
at the top of the list because he uh
came into work the morning after he got
a concussion and then actually went on
the road with me to South Carolina but
that's a basic job expectation okay that
is not that's not going above and be
come on who doesn't do that uh question
from Jessica Michael how do I tell my
husband to be more financially
responsible he has made poor financial
decisions before he finally admitted
that we've accumulated over $15,000 in
debt that I was unaware of oh my
goodness we're working hard to pay it
off because I want to quit my job to
stay home with our two young kids and
homeschool them but occasionally I will
open a statement from an account that I
thought was closed and he responds with
I'm not perfect oof he comes from a
family that did not handle money well he
has made other poor and impulsive
decisions in the past that I am still
working to forgive I want to tell him to
man up because he has a family to take
care of of and that I need to be able to
trust him but I'm Catholic and I don't
know how to both submit to my husband's
leadership and tell him to be a
responsible leader at the same time how
do I address this in a way that will be
effective and not like I'm nagging thank
you so much for your show and all you do
I've learned a lot about my faith just
from listening to you that's very
kind you need
to uh put limits on the way that he can
spend money not that you need to do this
you as a family need to do this because
because in an ideal functioning
family the man would be the head of the
household in all ways and would be
responsible but in this case he has a
defect of his will he has a he has a
problem here he has a vice and that Vice
involves money so just as if if your
husband were an alcoholic you wouldn't
keep booze all over the house right
because your husband is a Spen Thrift
and I don't know how he's spending money
maybe he's a gambler maybe I don't know
what it is but however he's doing it
that's problem and so you don't want to
leave credit cards all over the house
either he he has this problem he
recognizes that he has this problem
which means that he ha has to for the
good of your marriage if I were him what
I would do is delegate to you the
financial um management of the household
I actually do that to my wife already
because I don't really know how to
manage a household whatsoever but I
would delegate that to my wife and I
would limit even the amount of credit
that I could run up I would call the
credit card company I would say lower my
credit limit I would call I I would give
up my debit card I would
not and it can feel infantilizing it can
feel uh shameful but there's no no shame
in that if you're a booze hound there's
no shame in keeping booze out of your
house you know you don't want to put
yourself in the near occasion of sin you
don't want to put yourself that close to
Temptation because you know your own
weaknesses that's actually very manly
that's very reasonable to do and in this
case his weakness is money so he's got
to be kept away from the money he's got
to keep himself away from the money he's
got to put limits on it if you're if
you're addicted to porn we were talking
about porn earlier in the show then you
got to put software on your computer to
stop you from going to the porn websites
if you're addicted to womanizing then
you got to not you know not go to the
club or wherever you meet
women you got to you've got to know your
limits and you've got to you've got to
keep yourself away from Temptation in
order to even have the possibility to
build up habits of virtue so that at
some point he can be trusted again but
otherwise if you don't do that if if his
pride if his selfish Pride will keep him
from doing that your likelihood of being
divorced even if you're a practicing
Catholic and and a devout Catholic is is
significantly higher than it should be
gota got to know your limits okay the
rest of the show continues now you don't
want to miss it become a member use code
NES canw has a check out for two months
free on all annual
plans
[Music]
yes